you know i talked to someone who's a
parent of a dyslexic child about how
so many of the most successful
entrepreneurs are dyslexic
i don't know if you've connected with
other people on that i think barbara
corcoran is actually in that category
too where she is dyslexia is also like
you this
entrepreneurial titan eight of 12 sharks
are just like i
i've been on the show dyslexic kevin is
dyslexic barbara's dyslexic i'm dyslexic
branson's dyslexic i believe rohan is
dyslexic
so since you lived this what do you
attribute
that incredible correlation to because
having two-thirds of sharks being
dyslexic is staggering
i think that well i know that i can
attribute my dyslexia to
it is that whenever i would read
something
i would have to read it many times
because i wasn't not certain that i
absorbed the information the right way
and even after that like i i rethink and
grow rich every
every other year um and methodology and
various other books but
um after that i also used to go out and
try to practice
the things that i thought that i read
because i still wasn't
certain that i absorbed the information
the right way so going out to practice
things would
would really help me perfect whatever i
was doing
[Music]
on today's episode of yang speaks damon
john
the ceo of fubu investor
businessman titan and
recurring shark on the hit show
shark tank joins
the conversation with andrew yang and i
will say this
before listening andrew did this episode
just hours after passing a kidney stone
so thoughts and prayers for andrew he is
recovering
um but he's also a psychopath who
powered through this thing uh it's
pretty cool
so uh andrew you're
crazy and a badass and damon john's also
badass you guys are gonna love this
episode so tune in damon john joining
yang speaks
right now
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to yang speaks
my friend fellow presidential ambassador
of global entrepreneurship
and the obama administration legendary
entrepreneur you probably know him from
shark tank or from
boo-boo which freaking helped shape the
culture i grew up in
damon john what's up man it's so great
to see you
uh and this has been such like a crazy
time
uh you know the last time you and i saw
each other in person so
people would never believe this but the
office of my presidential campaign was
in the same office
as your your uh co-working space empire
uh so i would just bump into you in the
elevator and just keep running into each
other
yeah and then the world changed
obviously in in march how's the
have you been like this last number of
months i listen i've been great man um
thank god my whole family is healthy and
safe and
we did lose a lot of people you know
whether
employees families and friends you know
probably uh you know because new york
was hit so hard so probably about
you know i heard you know probably about
40 people we lost the
in the earlier and the later excuse me
in the early part of last year
um but overall you know
blessed healthy and uh and still around
to fight another day
yeah it's been so brutal damon i know so
many people lost friends family members
and
loved ones this past number of months i
mean my parents
frankly left the country because we
thought that was the safest thing for
them to do
it was was for them to leave and that it
turns out that was probably right
uh and then i got covid myself a couple
months ago which was
an ordeal and you know i don't think i
was ever in any real danger
but it sucked for sure um so
yeah the the fact that you lost people
you knew man that that's so hard i'm
sorry
yeah i think it's brought awareness to a
lot of people and the value of life
and and and how we can't take things for
granted and we just need to
to you know rebuild in all all aspects
of life you know so
we'll move on from there and you know i
hope nobody else has to face this type
of stuff
well you're an incredibly positive
person one of the most
like productive people i've ever had the
privilege of knowing
uh and i i do want to talk to you a
little bit about like the yankees cap
you've got on like the
[Laughter]
your new york roots now because when i
referred to fubu i remember the first
time
i uh got exposed to fubu was during that
gap commercial with ll cool j
where he was just like four hours by us
and then i was so confused
even and that day because i was like
wait a minute did that guy just like
advertise another clothing brand while
he was
uh in a video for the gap
there were a lot of people that were
extremely confused when that happened
you know so so the story goes that ll
you know did put he wore a baseball cap
and he put for us by us on the low in
the gap ad
and um uh because he was frustrated he
felt the the gap wasn't really taking
you know they didn't they didn't respect
hip-hop they didn't respect him they
just wanted to
hire him to do this commercial um and
you know i think this reflects kind of
what we're seeing going on where
we talk about diversity and inclusion
because the gap
ended up spending 30 million dollars
airing that ad and i remember us in the
office looking at this going
at first i mean my mouth just dropped
the first week
the second week my mouth was still
dropped but by
by the three and a half weeks in i was
like
these idiots don't know what they did
what's happening because
they didn't have anybody that
represented the culture whether of color
or whether of music orientation
in the company so if you look at you
look at sometimes how
diversity and inclusion is probably
probably smart
you know to have a little bit of other
opinions because think about it they
spent 30 million dollars airing football
ads now i do have to give it up to the
gap you know what they did after that
they did their analytics right
uh and they realized that the target hit
market they were trying to hit
increase 300 percent because the kids
thought they can get fubu
at the gap they go out and rerun the ad
and i got to tell you
they were brilliant for doing that and
i'm super happy that they did that as
well
that's an incredible story so that was
in the
early 90s when you guys were still
coming up and one of the stories that
you told me and that i got from your
book uh was
your first business was driving a van
across queens i think it was
where you would just stop and people
would get on it how much money would
they give you to get on the van
a dollar dollar each so in new york they
we call them
uh you can either call them gypsy cabs
or what they call them dollar
dollar vans and they're they're heavily
in brooklyn and queens
where we go up and down the bus route um
and people hop on and hop off and give
you a dollar
um and you know it was it was my
business for a long period of time but i
worked for about four years doing that
and then i was just drained because even
though i'm making 300 a day i was
i was grossing 300 a day i was probably
netting 15
a day by the time i pay for all my um
my beat up band pay for the gas and by
the way it's not legal if you don't have
uh
taxi and limousine commission issued
plates so i get one ticket from the
department of transportation for picking
up in a bus stop
that was 2 500 so uh
that was uh that was a lesson i learned
about the difference of grossing and
netting
and um and how you should have all the
right things in place to run a business
because
if you don't you can you can really hurt
yourself
so you went from driving back and forth
and during that time i think you were
starting to dabble in a tire is that
right like what ski hats were some of
your first products
yeah it was you know it was my um my my
couple of hats that i sold on um
you know uh you know on the corner and
then i would go and buy
shirts and stuff with just characters on
it and then i would fill my van filled
with because i'll take the seats out of
the van
and then i'd fill it filled with super
soakers and during
the greek fest or picnic i go down to
jones beach and sell the super soakers
to all the kids so
i was always trying to find a way to to
make a couple of bucks
well fubu ended up being this incredible
leap of faith for your family your mom
i think she mortgaged the house to get
you the startup capital after she saw
that the business had potential
what a freaking family
you know love loyalty story that is
because i i feel like a lot of
others would um you know wouldn't have
had that kind of belief or confidence
yeah mom had faith man um you know she
knew that i was working on the house as
well i was i was i was paying a lot of
the bills at some time you know her
you know she worked her jobs i did and
we collectively put together
she wouldn't necessarily give me the
money just out of you know a leave of
paper but i had 300 000
in orders and i came home and i got
turned down by 27 banks now
i rightfully so got turned down my 27
banks because i was not using the house
as collateral
and i didn't know how i didn't have
financial intelligence so
i i wasn't really filling out a loan
application the way that it should be
filled out
um but she did say this is all we have
this house so let's mortgage the house
and
uh then when you you know get the goods
out you put the money back in as soon as
you make the money
you put the money back in and she went
out and she got a hundred thousand
dollar loan on our house and i have no
idea because the house is worth 75
so to till today i haven't asked what
she did for the rest of the money but i
got to tell you
you know shout out to moms moms are the
ultimate entrepreneurs they figure it
out
well shoot man i'm not sure those banks
were right
not giving you that loan if you had 300
000
orders and that's something i would love
to see change
frankly like if there is an entrepreneur
like you coming up and
you have traction and are starting to
get momentum i mean someone has to
believe uh in your growth i think
and you know you see all these frankly
like tv commercials where the banks are
all like we're going to be a partner in
your growth
you'd like to see that that play out for
[Music]
real
all right this episode of yank speaks is
brought to you by better help
i am a happy customer of better help
right now so i'm not going to say the
name of my therapist because that might
be weird but i'll pretend her name is
sarah
and she's amazing and it's like this for
me it's a combination of
just someone to talk to a bit of life
coaching
i do it once a week i look forward to it
honestly
and what i find it's like a healthy
outlet instead of just thinking
this stuff in your mind you've now
gotten it out there and you decide
for me it's like i decide what is worth
focusing on what's worth improving on
and what's worth getting rid of and
never think about again
so people can use this for depression
stress anxiety relationships sleeping
trauma
anger family conflicts you name it it's
convenient it's confidential
so if you want to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor betterhelp.com
yang so join over 1 million people
including yours truly
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelp.com help
slash yang betterhelp.com
today's episode is brought to you by
athletic greens
it's the most comprehensive daily
nutritional beverage i've ever had
and it's so simple need a little energy
need a little pick me up just worked out
want to have some better wanna get your
vegetables better you're not eating your
vegetable enough you just open these
packets
pour a little in some water throw it
back sip on it throw it in a smoothie it
tastes great it's great for you
one tasty scoop of athletic greens
contains 75 vitamins minerals and whole
foods source
ingredients including a multivitamin
multimineral probiotic green superfood
blend that's my favorite and more
they all work together to fill in the
nutritional gaps in your diet increase
your energy and focus and aid with
digestion to support a healthy immune
system this is also preventing you from
having to take lots and lots of vitamins
so
here's the deal we are doubling down on
supporting your immune system with
athletic greens during these
winter to spring months so we're giving
our audience a free supply of vitamin
d and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit our link
today you'll never have to buy vitamin d
again so visit
athleticgreens.com yang join health
experts athletes and health conscious
go-getters around the world
make a commitment to their health every
single day again
athleticgreens.comyang get your free
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs today
so this was around the time we were
talking about where fubu really took off
right i started foot189 i closed it
three times from 89 to 92.
then i started again in 92 with my
buddies um
i would start getting public recognition
around 95
and like 96 97 is when i started
i got i got obviously my my bigger
manufacturing and distribution deal
and i got food watch the market and
that's when it started to really hit
around 97.98
well that that's incredible man and so
how big did the operation get and
when did you for example transition out
of
your home to like an office to a
manufacturing facility and all the rest
of it because that must have been an
incredible time
you must have been still over your skis
in a lot of ways like figuring out
[Laughter]
like you know i think it was the year 96
i had moved three times i
because my house i turned my house into
a factory and then i got my deal
and i was no i was now uh stationed in
the empire state building
um you know the word was out the food
was making money so
i was i was fearful for my life uh you
know at
in back in the neighborhood so i
couldn't return back to that house and
then
i had moved uh i moved my my wife uh who
was my girlfriend the time we just had a
baby i moved her to one place i moved
i moved to manhattan just for four
months so i can be right there at the
office
and um and then we finally we moved like
two more times we finally got our house
uh in long island sands point right
around 98.
i was in asia i was in uh europe and uh
i was traveling most of the time in
factories and stuff like that my life
was just a whirlwind and we were
right around 98 i think we started to we
we started to do around 350 uh 350
million
annual sales and um it was it was a lot
going on
uh you know and in in the apparel
business that's a great number but it's
not the biggest number i mean you think
you know people like nike are doing 30
billion a year you know and
ralph lauren probably three billion a
year but 350 million was uh
was was was a lot for me you know i was
i told you i was working a van i was
netting 15
a day so 350 million was was quite a
quite over my skis well
so you you built this household
name brand uh and then i think a lot of
these retailers are trying to get a
piece of the action
in different ways uh fubu is now
featured
in the smithsonian's national museum of
african american history and culture
which must be a real point of pride it's
like what the heck clothing brand makes
it into the smithsonian
and over time i mean that 350 million
peak mean you earned
over 6 billion in global sales over all
the years that that fubu was in
operation
but i do have the sense that you know
like you were learning as you were going
like what are like the giant lessons you
took
from that the big takeaways were that
there are good and bad people
you know i came from the streets and i i
i love this this to make apparel for
this new genre of music and i was trying
to escape the clutches of drug dealers
and various other things i fell in the
streets but
uh the reality is when you have a lot of
money flowing through systems there's a
lot of bad people too they just don't
come with a gun they come with a pen
you know so be careful um it also
uh lessons were trust your gut because
there may be a lot of things that look
good on paper or a person that looks
good in person but if your gut tells you
something and you can't necessarily
articulate
why you don't think you should do the
deal or why it's not in the best
interest
don't do it um you know and i i you know
it always ends up you know you need to
trust your gut
i think cockiness also comes into play
when you are
on top uh have a healthy paranoia
and the customers first um don't get too
cocky
don't don't uh don't think that you know
it all and or you
you can solve everything with money you
know um
so uh you know that came with it also
to understand the diversity in in your
company of the diversity of gender and
age and color and creed and beliefs and
and to make sure there are experts in
there i didn't know this but i didn't
realize that every for every 50 people
you probably need an hr person
so i became a shrink at the end of the
day in my company because i wanted
people to feel like there was an open
door policy and you can speak to me at
any time
but i can't be an expert in everything i
can't be an expert in the way to
communicate with other adults and
different genders and different
uh idealisms and you need people there
because your
your team is your that's your bread and
butter man that's your that's your
bloodline
and you may you need to make sure that
you are working just as hard and
listening to these people that work just
as hard for you
um to to make them feel comfortable
because then if you do that they will
they will they will bust their butt for
you
that's beautiful and profound it's very
human damon i'm going to project
i'm just going to share a story from the
my presidential campaign
uh because i sense that you might have
had a similar experience with booboo
uh where so no one really thought my
running for president was a great idea
initially
and then as we gathered momentum we
raised
maybe 10 million dollars in like a
three-month period which ended up making
national headlines
and then all of a sudden all of these
political consultants
and firms came out of the woodwork where
they showed up and were like hey you
uh need our advice on this you need to
do this like this is the way that you
grow
and your it's your first time doing it
so you're like okay
like these people have been through
versions of this so
like i need to hear them out uh but then
some of them are full of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but but but it takes you a while to
figure out which is which
because some of them actually are
sharing very valuable hard-won
experience and you know their guidance
is invaluable and others are just there
like
to be parasitic and just freaking latch
onto you and try and siphon off as much
money as they can
during the time they have yeah 100 and i
you know listen i believe that that is a
big
that is a big um aspect of anybody's
success you know not only the
the great times that you succeeded and
the people around you the great people
but getting screwed or
or or seeing the bad side of it um you
know because you could
and especially in any industry i'm sure
there's no difference in politics right
by the time i was you know by the time
you know fubu started to slow down and i
acquired my other companies
i already know who to deal with or not
because i've been screwed by everybody
right so i knew i knew who the crooks
were and i knew who the good people were
um and i i think in any industry people
people people start to get that and that
that's what comes with age and
experience and wisdom
and and and and trying you know and and
and trials and tribulations
[Music]
[Applause]
okay last time i did a hellotushy ad
which we love the new york post wrote a
piece on this and so i'm hoping they do
it again so new york post if you're
listening here's a hello tushy bidet ad
for you and it's awesome the future of
toileting has arrived okay it's
actually been around for centuries but
they've been very expensive before
now and helatoshi has brought the cost
down and the new hello tushy 3.0 modern
bidet attachment is here to level the
playing field it's stylish
eco-friendly easy to install and
affordable so
it this new one actually like cleans
itself before and afters they've got
this smart spray
automatic like self-cleaning nozzle
which is awesome so it attaches to your
existing toilet
no electricity no additional plumbing
and cuts toilet paper use by 80 percent
hello tushy is good for the environment
big fan of the days you also get a one
year 12 month warranty so
check it out for a 60 day risk free
guarantee and our listeners can go to
hellotushi.com to get 10
off a bidet plus free shipping so get 10
off
plus free shipping get your butt clean
and hello tushie.com hello digi.com
yang that's hellotushy.com
[Applause]
all right if you've been listening the
show for a while you've probably heard
me talk about my helix mattress
andrew talks about his well helix has
left the bedroom and started making
sofas and they launched a new company
called all form
and the sofas are awesome
so you can customize this thing online
you can get up to an eight seat
sectional i've got a gray three seat
couch with like a long kind of leg
extension ottoman situation
and i love it you can spill on it like a
dumbass and it doesn't stain
it's comfy like a helix mattress it
looks amazing and
look honestly it was so easy to assemble
i'm an idiot when it comes to stuff and
it's built like a rock it's fantastic so
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com they offer a forever
warranty literally forever and you get
100 days to decide if you like it or not
and all form is offering 20 off all
orders for our listeners at allform.com
yang that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
yang get your 20 off get your awesome
sofa couch whatever you want
it's amazing you won't regret it do it
[Music]
[Applause]
so you were running a whole series of
businesses and then you wound up
hitting the public eye in a huge way
uh maybe 2009 2010 when shark tank
starts hitting the scene
and i remember seeing the bios and being
like oh my gosh
like freaking damon the founder of
fubu's like on this show
it like brought me back to my childhood
honestly and like you know like all of
like the
uh the the cool factor that uh you know
you brought to
neighborhoods all around the country uh
and on shark tank
you've now invested it seems like 10
million of your own money
uh in and how many businesses like how
many uh enterprises you're involved with
now
i think we're at 88. that's incredible
and a lot of people who are fans of
shark tank actually you know know
those businesses well because they
watched that episode and they they saw
you decide to commit to
uh bomba or the uh the
uh bbq's boneless ribs or like any of
the other
uh places that that you've invested in i
gotta say man like i see you
on the show and i imagine these 88
entrepreneurs and i'm just like you must
feel like this
head of the this like extended
household of like dozens of
entrepreneurs
who are all over the country trying to
make things happen and you're like the
godfather
you know i'm really curious about what
that's like
because you know i know you well enough
to know that you're like a high
character stand-up guy where you're
going to like you know want the best for
these people
and actually like genuinely mentor them
uh
but at the same time like i was like man
like you know some of these
uh businesses i'm sure could use damon
all the time
try try to guide them through the
hurdles you know
i got to tell you i'm very transparent
i'm very open with all the people that i
invest in but
you know i'm a minority stakeholder in
any and all their companies and some of
them
truly value what i say and some of them
couldn't care less
um because uh you know andrew you've
seen startups for years and
uh you know if you look at my 88 or
investments or whatever they are
so this is really the way it works right
30 of them
one-third is probably not doing well and
covet is only uh
shortened their lifespan because they
probably weren't able to transition they
they they weren't somebody who was uh
educating themselves or
understanding where the digital world
was going in
gotta probably close those businesses
down another third of them like bombers
they don't call me because if i say
something i'll screw them up they're so
brilliant you know when you have a great
founder or a great founding team
they'll call you they'll ask you ten
things you'll give them 10 answers and
they'll maybe use one because they're
sorting out all the things that work for
them so
i don't even want to bother them it's
the third it's the one-third in the
middle that is on the fence and they
need some they need some nurturing they
don't whatever the case is but
um often you know the theory on shark
tank is a lot of people believe that we
just roll up and give you the money
i learned that the first year when i was
out of 750 000 dollars by not asking for
what are your
use you know the use of proceeds you
know how are you going to use the money
so now sometimes my entrepreneurs aren't
really big fans they go
all right d well you know if you give us
you know all the money we'll no i'm
going to give you 25
of the money and you need to get the
business to here and then that'll
activate the other 25
so but at the end of the day they
respect me i hope they do i respect all
them for allowing me to be part of their
dream but
i wouldn't call myself the godfather
i'll call myself the
the weird cousin in the family you know
uh and
they'll be like i don't know if we
should talk to damon about it but it it
is just an opportunity it is a great
opportunity for me to
be part of the ones who are successful
and the ones that fail
i i'm really happy that they allowed me
to be part of their dream and maybe they
and i never mention the ones who fail
because i don't want to mess up who they
are because you know
somebody who failed in this business and
maybe their third they're gonna hit
they're gonna hit uh they're gonna hit
the
goal mine on their fifth business right
they just they just learn to start over
a little more wisely
well i'm very open about the fact that
my first company
was a total failure like i joke all the
time
and i was like a mini rise in maximum
fall and it felt like the end of the
world at the time
i was in my mid-20s i'd lost investors
uh
six figures an investment it seemed like
all the money in the world at the time
and then you pick yourself up and you
learn from it
and you you know get back at it uh and
you know you certainly embody that
better than just about anyone i actually
love the characterization of you as the
weird cousin
uh be in part because what you said
about the fact that when founders really
have
their fingers on the pulse of their
business they really do know it best
uh and and one of the toughest things
about being an entrepreneur
which i'd alluded to earlier is figuring
out
what to block out really like you get
subject to so many
sources of advice and input
that's actually true in politics too you
you
do get like a lot of people have an
opinion about whatever you're doing
uh and so i think one of like the
biggest things you have to do is
uh develop your own judgment your own
confidence and say okay like that
this is my vision and this is what i
think i should be doing uh
and you sense entrepreneurs
developing that judgment over time like
when you start out you're much more
uh susceptible to the other people's
opinions particularly the people that
have done more than you which is you
know at that point like a lot of people
you feel like oh well like this person
knows better than me
but if the business is going to work you
have to know the business better than
anyone else
100 i mean it's your vision it's your
baby it's going to be the way that you
execute it should you take in as much
information as possible yes but you've
got to sift through it and see
what works for you again going back to
trusting your gut on some things
um taking uh failing fast but taking
many many steps to
realize what your what the clutter is
you got to get out of the way that
you tried or you know whatever the case
is um but yeah i mean you're going to
have to execute your business your own
way i mean because
i can sit there all day and give you
advice on how to run our apparel
business but that doesn't mean you're
running a fubu
you can be running a ladies business you
could be running a sportswear brand or
you could be
running a uh you know a high-end runway
brand well
if you take my advice on running a
high-end runway brand
you're in trouble what are you talking
about you you scream
high-fashion david i'm kidding
[Laughter]
you know what putting a big fb in a big
05 one jerseys ah that that's not that
difficult andrew i got to share that
with you it was all it was more we're
more of a marketing company than
anything else if you really think about
that
i've i've seen how good you look in
person damon i think you got a very very
keen fashion sense maybe it got
developed a little bit later
because by the time you and i met it was
like at the white house
you're right and when you say it you got
to be able to be
you know have your own vision and be
able to execute on the vision that you
have
as you take in information but do not
drown an opportunity when it comes to
information
one of my favorite things about you over
this past number of years is it's clear
that you're trying to
teach others and not just through shark
tank you know you've written a series of
books
uh i haven't read all your books but i
did read the power of broke which i
enjoyed a great deal
and found it to be really inspiring well
thank you
and even now you have like uh which i
love the name of this it's like damon on
demand
where it but i can sense that you're
genuinely just trying to edify
people who are coming up on some of the
lessons that you learned the hard way
uh and it's really beautiful man it's
very wholesome i think it's one reason
why you and i connected
uh because i i tried to do a lot of the
same things
but i think you hit on ways to do it at
scale in a way that
i frankly did not i know i appreciate it
we listen i i just think that
you know that's how we met and you know
what you're doing uh with all those
great uh
companies coming up and i just think
there's too much
crap out in the world though you know
everybody's showing kind of like the
sizzle reel
of their life and how you're supposed to
have shortcuts and
this and that one it's just not it's but
but it's not it's also
not that difficult you know if you could
see you know guys like you and me and
and
and people make it just you know we just
need to show some of the challenges in
it and
okay anything you do has challenges but
if you see a
little kid like me who's dyslexic and
a person of color that god left back
didn't go to high didn't go to college
excuse me and my father left when
and i was 10 years old and i didn't have
any money if you see that i can make it
then you can make it too
you know as long as long as we educate
you on on unaffordable ways to
to invest in yourself and uh and
hopefully go out there and accomplish
what you want to accomplish
now that's beautiful damon you know i
talked to someone who's a parent of a
dyslexic child about how
so many of the most successful
entrepreneurs are dyslexic
i don't know if you've connected with
other people on that i think barbara
corcoran is actually in that category
too where she is dyslexia is also like
you this
entrepreneurial titan eight of twelve
sharks are just like i
i've been on the show dyslexic kevin is
dyslexic barbara's dyslexic i'm dyslexic
branson's dyslexic i believe rohan is
dyslexic
so since you lived this what do you
attribute
that incredible correlation to because
having two-thirds of sharks being
dyslexic is staggering
i think that well i know that i can
attribute my dyslexia to
it is that um whenever i would read
something
i would have to read it many times
because i wasn't not certain that i
absorbed the information the right way
and even after that like i i rethink and
grow rich every every other year
um and methodology and various other
books but
um after that i also used to go out and
try to practice the things that
i thought that i read because i still
wasn't
certain that i absorbed the information
the right way so going out to practice
things would
would would really help me perfect
whatever i was doing
also um i i went to work to make money
often because in school they offered a
co-op program where you could work one
week and then go to school the next
and get a credit and that was my cheat
to get out of school
i went to work and it started it started
helping me understand and i was actually
working at first boston venture capital
firm as a as a messenger and i started
to hear these guys uh you know in the
lunchrooms always these big
these big brokers and you know hedge
fund guys talking and i think that i
i found a fascination for investing you
know when i was 16 years old just
sitting listening to these people so
it ended up coming back to me in my life
right around my my my
my uh beginning my 30s so this was a
co-op during high school because that's
awesome
is that right yeah there's co-op during
high school i spent my uh
my 10th 11th and 12th grade in co-op
well that's early and i love that i
think we should do that for more young
people
the stuff i've heard and read about why
dyslexic
entrepreneurs are so common is that
one you're not good at school so you're
looking around being like okay what else
can i do because like you know obviously
they're like if reading's difficult that
like teachers will probably think that
you're
not not that smart even though you're
like wait a minute i don't think that's
the problem
maybe one thing but the other thing is
that apparently dislikes
the young people find other ways to try
and accomplish things and often
those other ways involve other people so
one of the things that i've
read is that if let's say you're not
going to be good at
producing the paper you look around and
be like well who would be good at
producing this paper
then you're like hey maybe we could like
get together maybe i'm good at something
you're not so good at
yeah you know i think that you bring up
some good points but i do want to do i
do want to share that because so
like so seven presidents were dyslexic
uh i think i think something like 48
percent of entrepreneurs are dyslexic
uh uh a large percentage of chefs are
dyslexic
but also einstein was dyslexic but you
know there's a large uh
a large amount of people incarcerated
dyslexic too because
the same thing happens you know if
you're in school and you're not you know
because
if you have add adhd there are drugs
that can help those things so
since the drug companies getting paid
they can put out more information to
educate you
on add adhd but the only way to cure or
not cure to address dyslexia
is to learn more actually so when a kid
is in school
and they don't want to go huh in the
third grade or whatever because they
feel embarrassed
because kids are going to call them
stupid stuff a lot of times they don't
have the right resources around them
people will say hey i don't think you're
dumb at all why don't you stand on this
corner i'm going to show you how to make
some money
right so i i do want to make sure that
as we talk about this if parents think
that there's any challenge that kids are
having with whether lack of hearing or
adhd of course but of course with
dyslexia to go get it checked out
because um
it's not your kid looking for attention
you know they they don't have a pill to
get rid of it
you have to study even harder so but i
think it's something that is important
that that is so real and i don't know if
you know this but one of my boys is
autistic
and we got the diagnosis when he was
four
and felt so grateful because up to that
time we were struggling
but i agree with you if you have a child
or if there's a young person
hearing this you definitely should try
and
figure out what's going on and not just
say like well this is just the way it is
so you have your fingers on the pulse of
many businesses in many industries some
of them retail some of them consumer
facing
what are you seeing right now in terms
of uh the coveted economy
and the potential recovery because it
seems like there is a lot of pent up
energy obviously you've got this
uh money from the federal government
that we're starting to see trickle in
but like
do you are you seeing opportunities uh
early
on uh that people might not have noticed
yet
i'm not saying anything specific i'm
seeing um you know of course people who
were
reaching out directly to their customers
i'm seeing that that is working
i'm seeing people are extremely getting
extremely creative and doing a lot of
collaborations
um to try to bring more value to their
customers and borrow other people's
audiences
you know i am seeing that people are
trying to find ways
they're more rebellious and they're more
uh sensitive to matters
meaning that they want you or your
company
to reflect the people you serve um and
if not
they are going to go someplace else or
fight you
for not doing that i also see that
people want you to be more of a great
corporate citizen so if they're going to
be able to purchase they can purchase
from anybody
but they want to know what did you do
lately for somebody so unlike when i was
coming up and i would give at the end of
the year
they don't do that any longer they say
they that that that consumer is on zoom
or at the dining room table saying i
gave 30 times this year you go
how did you get 30 times this year you i
mean you only make you know you work at
a pizza shop well
every time i bought this i helped clean
up the ocean every time i bought this i
i tried to stop human trafficking and
every time i bought this you know
um i saved a furry friend of ours from
being euthanized
so there's a lot of things going on like
that and the biggest thing i'm seeing is
people hating the system they hate they
hate when they feel the system is
against them so
whether they're marching in the streets
with black lives matter signs of people
of all colors or whether they're saying
the american dream is if i have two
pennies to rub together i can get into
the stock market if i want and you
should not be able to hold me back
and i'm going to pull back the curtain
on the wizard of oz and show you
that i can do this too and if you don't
let me in i'm calling all my friends and
we're gonna we're gonna trash this place
you know so uh
you know these are all the things i'm
seeing and i think that we're we're
headed for you know i think that we're
going to have a little bit of a tough
time with whatever is going on with
these viruses and variants whatever the
case is but i do think that
we are going like you know and everybody
else is saying it we're heading for the
roaring 20s again
you know i think that people going to be
so um
pent up so excited about life
so cabin fever so whatever it is and i
think that we're going to be
we're just going to be doing business in
a whole new way and um
and those are all the things i'm seeing
um and uh you know end of the day
the only thing i can ever tell anybody
out there is to uh you know go after and
do things and invest and or start
businesses and things that you are
absolutely obsessed with
do not start saying oh today's nfts
tomorrow's crypto oh by the way i'm in a
sports card expert tomorrow
just go you know there's going to be so
many things being thrown away so much
information as you and i just said
really go after the things that you
really understand and you enjoy
thoroughly that you would be doing for
free if you you know or you know
if you could well that's great advice
damon
uh you are one of the world's great
entrepreneurs
it's a privilege to be your friend
brother you've touched so many lives
improved so many lives
uh and you just keep doing it every day
man you're
you're an inspiring figure uh and i hope
people take your advice and find the
thing that they
are obsessed about and dig into it uh
because i agree with you that's like the
best way to become successful people can
sense when you're
committed to something because you just
love that thing versus committed to
something because you think it's like
you know the opportunity of the moment
well i think i hope people get the same
thing out of you man you've been my
you've been my guy for
for quite some time and i've been proud
of all the things that you're doing
and anytime that i call you bang you
there you know and that's why anytime
you call me i'll be here for you brother
and i know there's a lot of people who
are going to benefit off of
whatever you are going to do you like to
serve man and i really appreciate you
thanks to you with the team man we'll be
in touch soon you got it brother peace
[Music]
you